Grant Hill joining us what was the first
hoops you that you uh war Wow uh back in
the day Dan probably the top ten adidas
those were big I think maybe late 70s
early 80s and I think the first the
first shoe that I got excited to wear
like it was like oh I got it I have to
go get them well probably the first Air
Jordans and I think I was in eighth
grade um and I thought I was you know I
thought I was the man when I was because
of my game but because of my shoes but
you had the Fela deal which that that
was different than everybody else right
ya know it was different it was
different and you know as we go back to
reminisce you know that wasn't sort of
on the radar when I was coming out of
college I was a big nike fan and one
Nikes my senior year at Duke when Coach
K switch from adidas to nike but you
know fila came to the came to the whole
heart they came to the basket hall with
with an offer and and so it was
different and we had we have fun we had
some shoes that came out that ironically
now I'm old enough to where you know the
kind of retro shoes need them totally
released and reissued and uh but yeah
have fun with fever back in the day and
had some cool shoes and look as a kid
growing up you know you always want to
have your own signature shoe and
commercials and all that stuff and so I
was you know lucky enough lucky enough
to do that do you have any memorabilia
you know it's funny you ask that I was
just in between games two and four
excuse me two and three I went home to
my parents house in the DC area and my
dad is a borderline my dad has
everything
he's a borderline hoarder and so here's
all his memorabilia all of my
memorabilia and it's like a shrine to
the hills in their home and so I mean
I'm talking he still has cleats in
storage that he wore when he played
football Yale so so it's cool you have a
parent that keeps everything and every
memory from when you play so I was there
and got a chance to show my kids some of
the whole videos and trophies and my
memorabilia his memorabilia it really is
pretty amazing and you know it's uh you
know it's cool it's cool to see I was
never into that stuff when I play and so
my parents were so I just kind of gave
all that by Rookie of the Year trophy
his rookie idiot trophy mine you know
Hakeem Olajuwon's Olympic jersey signed
just random stuff michael jordan shoes
from the all-star game in 97 Latos um
part of me how'd you get those I do that
wait so you say to my house can you tell
receive but you ask Mike after the game
or before Oh before the game oh okay and
you know but just all types of like
stuff that I either have myself or you
know but I that I had that I experienced
myself or I got from others and you know
I just kind of gave it to my parents
because I was young and irresponsible
and probably would lose it and now that
you're older you just you appreciate it
and obviously all of those all of those
items sort of bring back memories you
know and represent a certain time and
there's a story behind them and so so
yeah so I do have you know well Calvin
Hill has my dad has all the memorabilia
but um so hopefully he'll pass it on to
me one day he's Grant Hill joining us
from Cleveland but Kevin Love hasn't
been officially cleared to play but
let's say is cleared apply
you want him off the bench or do you
want him starting tonight you know I
think because of the matchup with Golden
State who obviously drops with a smaller
lineup even the starting lineup they
Bogut you know you have draymond Green
who's a power forward but not in the
traditional sense initiates the offense
plays on the perimeter they really
spread the court well with so much of us
some of those basketball experts talking
about Mozgov starting and going big like
last year in the finals Tehran Lugo's
small with Richard Jefferson and I
thought defensively that really helped I
don't think Golden State came ready to
play as well but I think just being able
to switch on the perimeter have more
another athletic body out there I think
it really sort of contributed to their
defensive presence to start the game and
so I would continue with that and it's
nothing personal look if love were to
play I think he can still have an
effective role he can still make an
impact and you're going to need him
healthy I think to close out the series
if you're Cleveland but right now look
playoffs are about adapting and
adjusting we saw Steve Kerr do it last
year which was really I think
instrumental and changed the tone of the
series and ultimately help Golden State
win you know you gotta do what you gotta
do and and so look I was in a similar
situation not in the finals but in in
college at do 1992 towards the end of
the year christian Laettner gets in a
fight with Cherokee parks in practice
Cherokee lands on my ankle I have a high
ankle sprain I missed the last two or
three maybe four games at a regular
season maybe five games I come back
coach Kay decides to bring me off the
bench and I came off the bench through
the entire ACC tournament and all the
way through the NCAA tournament now in
nineteen years I didn't like it but hey
that was what was sort of
cited and that's what Coach felt you
know what would help you know help us
win the ballgame and or excuse me win
the championship and and we did it and
we won and you know what years later you
know whatever feeling I was I had when
he first told me that you know back in
1992 you know I was probably upset but
you go with the program and winning is
is the ultimate so so anyway I was
younger I was immature but I still
bought in and we had great results and
so you know I know it's a little bit
different but for Kevin Love you want to
win yeah and I also think there's
uncertainty you don't know yet what
Kevin Love you're getting I mean he had
a concussion he was concussed to the
point where he was unable to play in
Game three so let him work his way back
let him maybe monitor as minutes a
little bit it takes the pressure off of
Kevin and allows him to come in and get
his rhythm and find out what he can do
and what he can contribute so you know
that's a long answer to your question
but i do think bringing Kevin Love if
he's able to play bring them off the
bench here in Game four were you ever in
a fight yeah I've was ever in a fight
yeah in the NBA mean first of all the
NBA no but I mean obviously growing up
yes a little bit definitely in college
I'd say we fought on did you fight in
pregnancy what in practice yeah nah we
didn't play so much in practice but we
fought a lot I think Laettner kind of
created an environment we we all kind of
fought each other and they're not in a
bad way but just yeah there was a lot of
on that team we're very juvenile and I
think at times we might have one in
spite of all that craziness but yes we
we we did have our moments and I think
that kind of you know that was sort of
the attitude in the mindset of who we
were as a team you know and but yeah we
did fight in fighting in the NBA but I
witnessed some really good fights in the
NBA with my teammates
in practice in the locker room yeah
what's the best one you know I kind of
feel like what happens I'm even I just
kind of talked about what happened to do
but you know I think I actually
ironically Stackhouse and Layton had a
pretty good flight ones on the airplane
that was pretty fun on the airplane yeah
that was pretty funny what wasn't funny
at the moment because you're 40,000 feet
up in the air but you know look stuff
happens and I think things go on
internally like things would happen with
a family and that happens I think in the
NBA it happens in college and you know I
think the beauty of it is guys can work
past it move forward learn from it
growth grow from it become even closer
as a result but that happened listen I
don't know if it happens as much now but
it certainly happened more so I think
back back in the day was there anybody
who didn't want to punch christian
Laettner on the team nah me I think I
think late did you ever want to punch
later I did punch I mean like yeah I
mean we would yeah I mean yeah I did I I
did want to do it and and and I did
before and you know what he punched me
before I mean like that happens and you
know in the film I think it was touched
on a little bit in his documentary which
which I think we all enjoyed at least I
enjoy yeah but yeah I mean we we fought
sometimes almost daily and I say we I'm
inserting me into that as well but it
was just that was the environment it was
fun it was juvenile it was we were all
kind of on edge a lot of trash-talking
but I think we were all so mature enough
to you know hug up go to dinner hangout
be friends that was just that was the
vibe and energy of our team and and I
think it contributed to our mindset and
ability to go out there and fight but it
was crazy and it was weird but it was
fun and I think we all enjoyed it he's
Grant Hill you can see him on NBA TV's
comprehensive NBA Finals pre and
postgame coverage including the expanded
90-minute live at the finals pregame
show that starts at seven Eastern
tonight grant always great to talk to
you thanks for joining us no problem
thanks for havin all right it's Grant
Hill trick show weekday mornings on
audience